I thought congressional hearings were
supposed to educate lawmakers but
today's are mostly partisan bickering
chairman Evan John was not recognized
did you ever have a point of what was
not recognized a point of order that I
don't see any education happen allowed
the right order Jim is not recognized
but members haven't tried to learn
things at hearings for a long time
maybe they don't want to look as
ignorant as senator orrin hatch did at
this Facebook hearing how do you sustain
a business model in which users don't
pay for your service senator we run ads
I say you'd think they'd know basic
facts before asking questions but no
have a seven-year-old granddaughter who
picked up her phone before the election
here Congressman Steve King asks
Google's CEO about an iPhone but I'd ask
you how does that show up on a
seven-year-olds iPhone who's playing a
kids game
congressman iPhone is made by a
different company lately they're eager
to attack big tech especially Mark
Zuckerberg because he's rich and
Facebook so powerful
last year he proposed the new
cryptocurrency called Libre I actually
don't know if Libre is gonna work but I
believe that it's important to try new
things
it is so Congress should let it instead
they someone into Washington were
representative Al Green grills him about
groups he partners with how many are
headed by women what does that have to
do with Libra congressman I do not know
the answer Green like many of these days
doesn't want to learn anything he wants
to sneer and score points how many of
them are minorities mr. Zuckerberg
congressman I I do not know off the top
of my head are there any members of the
lgbtq+ community give me a break these
hearings have changed a lot since they
were invented by the very first Congress
in 1789 founder George Mason said
members possess inquisitorial powers to
inspect the conduct of public offices
are you stupid
but today members use their time to
bully people missus DeVos have you ever
taken out a student loan Education
Secretary Betsy DeVos is a billionaire
Elizabeth Warren knows that yet she asks
I have any of your children had to
borrow money Warren wants to be seen
bashing a rich Republic I have been
fortunate not to uh have you had any
personal experience with the Pell grant
some in Congress bash rich people and
business for everything Tim Sloan was
boss of Wells Fargo mr. Sloan why was
the bank involved in the caging of
children really the bank helped caged
children III don't know how do they
answer that question because we weren't
others grabbed T V face time to claim
their more virtuous than others and I'm
not gonna sit here and allow this
committee to be used to say that e
cigarettes vaping jewel is not killing
our people two last examples when
military personnel were big stationed on
the island of Guam congressman Hank
Johnson said this my fear is that the
whole island will become so overly
populated that it will tip over and and
capsize excuse me we don't anticipate
that later representative Johnson said
he was joking but it didn't sound like
he was joking and then there was the
time when congresswoman Maxine Waters
grilled bankers about student loan debt
what are you guys doing to help us with
the student loan debt who would like to
answer first mr. Monahan big bang we'd
stopped making student loans in 2007 or
so oh so you don't do it anymore mr.
carbed we exited student lending in 2009
mr. Dimon when the government took over
student lending in 2010 or so we stopped
doing all student lending he's the chair
of the Financial Services Committee
embarrassed that she didn't know that at
the direction of her party government
took over student loans years ago I
don't know her staff didn't respond to
our emails watching the hearings
watching politicians score cheap points
and bully productive people should make
all of us want less government